death is the enemy
[Music]
the first enemy and the last
the enemy for Muslims and we still need
fighting
[Music]
I'm scared Archie what do you get
[Applause]
[Music]
you
hey everybody episode 6 trailer let's
break this down and if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything we only have a couple
episodes left in the season there will
be a couple of announcements about
what's going on during the off season
and how we're going to handle book stuff
next year because there's potentially to
Game of Thrones Song of Ice and Fire
books that will be released next year
but the whole idea of this trailer is
that it's sort of like their return to
doing a hardhome style episode north of
the wall but because of the way the
season is structured we're still going
to get scenes in other places like we
have the stuff that's going on at
Dragonstone we have the stuff that's
happening at Winterfell
so it's not all going to be set north of
the wall even though that is the event
of the episode like there's other stuff
that's happening but this right here
this is what's really going on this is
the thing that everybody's going to be
talking about after the episode in a
couple of you have already spotted a
really weird cut that they have in here
so it looks like the Hound is using the
exact same Warhammer the Gendry is so
people were a little confused by that
last night like what's the deal why do
they have the same hammer so what I
think is going on here is that they just
cut the trailer in a weird way in the
Hound is just using gendry's hammer and
it's just from later in the episode
so like andrey maybe drops it while he's
fighting the white walkers in the hound
picks it up that doesn't necessarily
mean the Gendry dies but i think the
idea here is that barrack is saying that
death is the enemy the enemy always wins
meaning that he expects to die they'll
probably be shedding a whole lot of
their cast in this episode so let's just
do death predictions really quick and
I'll say right off the bat I do think
that they'll wind up killing
Littlefinger this season but I don't
know if it's going to happen in episode
6 or if they'll push it to episode 7
because they have this Sansa plot that
they're hyping up you don't see
Littlefinger in the trailer that much
but he's a big part of the episode
because he planted that letter that
Sansa was forced to write during season
1 about Ned Stark being completely out
of his wits denouncing him as a traitor
so just remains to be seen how much they
stretch that Winterfell plot out because
that's basically what's happening at
Winterfell right now there's nothing
else that's going on beyond brand just
trying to help them out north of the
wall so just open up a tab separately
from Littlefinger from all the stuff
that's happening north of the wall so
north of the wall death predictions
magnet
since seven this is going from my most
likely to die to my least likely
obviously I think that Jon Snow is the
least likely to die because he's so
critical for the plot so he's got that
heavy plot armor protecting him but
starting with most likely to die
beric Dondarrion Thoreau Samir tormund
Gendry Jorah the hound and then
obviously Jon Snow and I know a lot of
people are like where's benjin I feel
like if he's going to come back this is
the episode to do it he's also on that
death predictions list but I don't want
to talk about him too much because he's
not really in the trailer you just have
to remember that the dead cannot pass
beyond the wall that's what the
enchantment does is it prevents people
who are either half turned like benjin
or people who are full white from
crossing so they haven't really
articulated on it yet but bran was
marked by the night king supposedly that
has something to do with him making it
south of the wall it also enables him to
sort of track bran where he is so like
he can see him at Winterfell in that
sort of psychic weirwood Network space
where they're looking at the past
present and future I still want to know
if they're going to have some sort of
psychic battle before the end of season
8 but it sounds like that might not wind
up happening this season but I do feel
like brand has extra abilities that he
just hasn't completely figured out yet
they do it on comic book TV shows all
the time where like the super hero gets
powers but it takes him a couple seasons
to unlock all the crazy abilities that
he has in the comics like all the
abilities that he has all the knowledge
is already there in his brain it's just
that he hasn't figured out how to make
use of it in the way that the three-eyed
Raven was so he just needs more time to
mess with that but I know a lot of
people will be super bummed if Kendra
dies they want that Arya reunion as much
as that would be total fanservice
I do feel like they brought Gendry back
just for this moment here just is a bit
of fanservice to say hey we didn't
completely forget about this character
so early on when it seemed like he was
coming back I was like oh man there's
all these things they could use him for
he's this master blacksmith they could
learn how to remake Valyrian steel arm
everyone that would be a great way to
use the Gendry character even if he
wasn't around for every single episode
but it kind of seems like they're not
going in that direction and because
there's only six episodes in the final
season it just remains to be seen so
cross your fingers for Gendry escaping
Aria is going to be so pissed with John
if she finds out the Gendry went north
of the wall there are a couple
references the things that happened
earlier in the season - so as they walk
into the frozen north you see the Hound
double-take as he looks at the mountains
it seems like an arrowhead that's what
he saw in his vision and then you have
this big open area with the sort of
platform of rocks in the middle that's
sort of the staging area where you see
John and the others see the whites start
to spill through that little opening
there is they start running for their
lives to make it to that we got our
brief look at it earlier in the trailer
so all these themes of Jon Snow and them
standing here just from a little bit
later in the episode there are only
three of them on that rock so that does
make me wonder if the others have died
by the time they're standing there but I
think that's just because you can't see
behind them so it's not so much a
question of who's going to die its of
how fast are they going to kill all
these people because I do think that
more than half of the group guaranteed
is going to die but a very small chance
that Jon Snow is the only person that
survives because we do see this lone
horse riding off so I think that's Jon
Snow just barely escaping with his life
and that's probably benjen's horse so
just remind everyone please do not post
spoilers for the episode in the comments
obviously we're not going to be able to
see it till next week once we get a
little bit closer to the finale we can
start making predictions for season 8
some of you have already started to do
that and they have already finished all
of the scripts there are six episodes in
season eight the writing is all done the
thing that they're doing now before they
actually start shooting the episodes is
just figuring out how they're going to
accomplish that because they've kind of
been referring it to 6 2 hour movies but
that's not guaranteed so we might get
six movies for Game of Thrones season 8
which would be awesome considering that
we would normally get 10 episodes but
we'll see how that goes we'll talk about
that more after this season we don't
really see Cersei anywhere in this
trailer but there were so many people on
my episode 5 video that are absolutely
convinced that Cersei is lying about
that baby
so we'll see when the episode drops
because they do sort of jump forward in
time quite a bit and Cersei doesn't look
like she's anywhere near her second
trimester like she's barely showing you
can't tell with those heavier
that she has on but I will say yes I do
think that she's completely irredeemable
now that she's lost her children the
whole idea is that she's completely
Unchained it's totally possible that
she's faking that baby so that Jamie
won't go anywhere but I don't think that
she's worried about that at this point I
think the whole reason for that baby on
the TV show which does not exist in the
book she doesn't get pregnant again in
the books is all about giving you the
semblance of hope the Cersei will see
reason agree to the armistice see the
white and then help out so they'll lay
down their arms they'll all come
together the way that they need to
divide the army of the dead because the
whole thing about Cersei is that her
children were basically her soul so when
her children died her soul died too
so she's completely Unchained now so if
she were to have another child it's
almost like she would get her soul back
and it would be something to redeem her
but if that baby were to die then she
would just go off the rails which I do
think that it well I think it'll blow up
in everyone's faces in Cersei will do
something super terrible and we'll
finally get to see Jaime just go that's
enough of this I'm out of here there's
all that Jon Snow Targaryen Rhaegar
annulment talk from last week's episode
there's so much stuff happening with
what's going on north of the wall I'm
not expecting them to immediately follow
up with the Rhaegar bomb that Gilly
dropped maybe they'll say that for
episode 7 there'll be at least one more
scene to sort of touch on that and
broaden the context like they wouldn't
just leave you hanging with that until
season 8 so what's going to happen next
is I'll post my Q&A video just leave all
the questions that you want me to
include there is a new round of that HBO
now giveaway I'll just announce the
winner when I post that Q&A video what's
going to start happening in the off
season is that they'll start spinning up
Westworld they're shooting they're going
to be premiering that probably in the
spring next year in the books that
George R Martin might be releasing next
year he just casually dropped that he
might have two books to release next
year is fire in blood the Targaryen
family history book that he's been
talking about for a long time that's
actually pretty cool it's just like a
history of Song of Ice and Fire told
from the perspective of the Targaryen
family and then obviously winds of
winter so he just casually saying that
there might be two books instead of just
winds of winter so what will happen is
if it takes them till 2019 to get season
eight out then most of my Game of
Thrones bonus
videos between show stuff will be booked
videos next year so you have plenty of
time to catch up if you haven't started
reading the books yet but while you wait
for everything you can click here for my
episode 5 video again and you can click
here to learn all about the children's
the forest and the White Walkers symbols
that Jon Snow found thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight